it's a boule Capcom exclusive euros
power 98.3 where him pile is man bull
that Capcom you already know in front of
me right now I got the homie
Chamillionaire in the building so remain
Chamillionaire I gotta tell you bro
I've been a big fan of yours for years
man I used to make a lot of money off
your mixtapes when I was like 17 I've
been a fan of yours too man I wish I
could believe your interviews but I
can't so man I'm telling you
hey the song never let you down was like
my profile song on MySpace forever oh
yeah pretty sure it still is I really
believe you are really bad that song was
like that song made me like want to go
get money like in the woods you know I
had to do like a remix today I had like
everybody everybody you know everybody
who ever wrapped in Texas was on my
money yeah unfortunately the label kind
of like yeah do some pasta you know that
was a crazy record hey I want to talk to
you man because you have a storied
career man you you know of course you're
probably at all the artists who broke
out of Texas you know in the oh five era
you know it was yourself Mike Jones
until you probably my favorite man I
thought you know music you dropped the
sound of revenge yeah what shot did big
things big things the second album was
really dope ultimate victory was the
clea clean it was critically acclaimed
album but commercially it didn't perform
like the first one yeah and and then
since I know the venom I was waiting for
venom man yeah venom a lot of people
somebody hit me today and was like yo
I'm waiting on them can you take it too
long right it's not like when I love
Universal that was the album I was
working on in denim
the album was like you know I thought it
was turning out pretty good but they had
a different direction that they wanted
me to go which is a little bit more pop
you know I don't want to go that
direction and no so we didn't see eye to
eye so I wanted to leave Universal I was
like you know I want to leave they don't
want to let me out so after you know
little negotiation on Miami we ended up
getting out of there but they were like
you're not taking any of the music and I
was like cool it was like you're really
gonna leave and not like take not into
music and just start over
that's all and leaked it as well the
phantom sandwich you know I'm a man of
my word if I say I'm not gonna I'm just
happy to let me out because they didn't
have them yet I wanted to yeah I mean
they want to keep me on they still make
money off of me I still you know have a
deal with Universal publishing so we
still have business together you know we
still see you don't know yes yes I don't
wanna burn bridges you never know you
know so I never leaked any of the stuff
even though man I ain't gonna lie man I
was in the studio the other day
listening to drive like man if I were to
put this out man it'd be crazy yeah so
it's hard to start over but I'm proud of
the music that I'm making now you know a
lot of people be like what's taking so
long why you ain't dropped the album in
a long time I'm not one of these people
that's like trying to keep up with the
relevancy of other rappers right it's
just not my thing
you know I mean um I focus on my craft
and get our idea and not work on it and
I have fun doing it so we've been going
across the world shooting all these
videos because I have this big plan in
my head about how I want to release the
next project and I've been you know
trying to make that happen
you've been heavy uh still doing the
mixtapes of course which was you know
initially your your kind of your your
roots in hip-hop is that you're doing
the mixtapes
yeah um and then you just drop the EP
right you guys drop the EP called
elevate you know I drop a lot of that
stuff directly for my website and the
goal behind that it's just you know
accumulate you know email address it's
like a lot it's not a secret I've been
kind of heavy on use I think honestly
like you're one of the first rappers
that I really remember that used the
internet for the might of successful -
yeah it's it like really you know it's
his advantage and to this day I still do
it but I kind of just don't like you
know stand on a mountaintop and
screaming everybody are doing it like I
have a big mailing list I think one of
the biggest melon lists of like most
rappers you know and I use it
effectively
to sell a lot of records so a lot of
merch you know and I sell I directly
direct but because I'm not putting in
our iTunes a lot of people don't see it
so that's kind of the way it was when I
first started off I feel like
everything's coming back full circle cuz
I was doing so much and so many people
don't know you know like you're not
ahead of your time yeah you don't know
how many times I've over to somebody you
know you still get money you know just
look at her like we're still getting
money up get money well a whole life
that's what those so it's kind of like
selling records and independently doing
things that hasn't been a hard thing for
me but now doing it on the scale of what
I did major is the hard part you know
but I'm working on some things I think
come on pretty good you know so like
like generic like hip-hop fans like that
you you know that just know you for
riding dirty like yeah does that ever
get annoying like Amen this guy who did
write a dirty OH
eventually I know it's the different
curse because now I still do a lot of
shows and a lot of those fans that book
me you know we're going to presume we're
going to Dubai Russia
Joe they a lot of them only know about
run right here that's why it gets me
there so I can't really be that mad of
it but a lot of people in the states
when they kind of be like thinking that
you know you have a whole career for a
decade right yeah and you did all this
work all these mixtapes putting a lot of
work to do yeah and then they only
remember one song it's kind of like
people just skimming through the whole
life of people and it I can't be mad at
do a lot of people Joe button a lot of
people yeah yeah so I can't even really
be mad at it you know um I wanted to ask
you when you drop your section second
album like the lead singer was the hip
hop police joint yeah was that like your
choice or was that the labels choice I
think you might know the answer to this
already just for asking a question why
don't you reveal um no not like okay the
problems we have with Universal is Ellen
you get with a major right you start to
have all these ideas and then when
success comes everybody comes in
everybody wants to be a part of the
success now you know yeah so I remember
like when we drive around dirty
we had ridin dirty the whole time and
the label kind of was like you know he
don't got no hits you know I'm saying so
they was like we need to go find him
some big producers Timbaland Scott
Storch first I want to spend a lot of
money with Scott Storch and put I turn
it up what you did good you know yeah
million records off for that but after
that I didn't think I had no singles so
we convinced him like please man this
song just feels good you know it's not
like crazy bones the hottest artists
ever we don't think like that we just
feels good just and then they was like
well you don't really got a single so
cool we'll just go with this one and
because they were not refusing to go to
any other big artists so at the time I
had a little bit more clout put it out
rep it takes off you know so now the
next album everybody's all involved
everybody wants to be a part of it and
I'm trying to like keep control and it's
being a struggle between me and a label
and then um I had like a listening
session and it was like yo yeah I'll
take some records for the label to keep
him after me and I wasn't really even
ready at that time I was just like
halfway to the album so I just played
some records and you know anybody who's
familiar with my mixtapes I do like um
like a internet nerds attack yeah
during like a rolecall ravines were
unwrapping like other rappers it's kind
of just a creative thing I just do test
myself
so with hip-hop police it was that me
rapping and another voice I would never
think they would say as a single and I
just played it and that feeling that it
gave them because Slick Rick was on it
and he's from New York and they're all
from New York yeah they was like that's
the single and I was surprised I kind of
had like it was almost like a
continuation of ride and dirty like
low-key like I mean but it was like I
definitely wasn't trying to make no sign
I didn't even expect him to say it was
gonna be a single I remember when I when
I heard this is a dope record but it's
like a dope album cut yeah and that's
the way I made it but the problem was
that at that moment there was like
that's the single and it was like man
and I was like I argued I talked to you
know and ours we didn't think and nobody
wanted to like book against the system
you know that yeah then I got to the
point where I was like you know I have
been already kind of rebellious against
the label with a lot of things and at
that point I was like it felt like
everybody was on the other side of table
against me
you know it's not that I don't like the
record I like the right because I made
it but I didn't expect it to be a singer
I'm like man I gotta take this to Gregg
Street I gotta take this to Def Jam
blaster I'll take this to skip Cheatham
I know yourself I know you know Soulja
Boy is your land and everybody's like I
gotta go to these summer jams and
perform record form this and then it was
just like I'm pressing a button
I'm not gonna say no names but you know
no I was like I'm pressing a button and
I was like man what does that mean and
that means like the labels won't get
behind you just shut up
this is a song